حركه المواطنين من هذا الحاجز الذي اقيم
بالقرب من جامعه الاقصى حيث يتحرك
المواطنون باتجاه المناطق الغربيه اقصى
المناطق الغربيه للمحافظه بعد اقامه قوات
الاحتلال نقطه تفتيش قوات الاحتلال تعتقل
بين الحين والاخر عديد المواطنين حين
مرورهم عبر هذا الحادس او هذه النقطه التي
اقامتها قبل
[تصفيق]
يومين
هول انا اولادي اخذوهم هيهم تفرجوا عنهم
قبل نتف افرجوا عنهم متى اخذوهم الصبح من
امبارح اخذوهم في الليل وتفرجوا عنهم يعني
لا هم عاملين شي ولا هم مسويين شي
الحمدلله على سلامتك حبيبي الله يسلم
بردان شكلك ميتنا ه ايش اللي صار معك
وقفونا حجزو عند الدبابه وطخ على جنب
رجلينا وقفونا
وتفش ذلونا طخ علينا
لا في ميه ولا في مشرب
وح حجزو في الليل رجعونا قالوه في الاخر
ارجعوا غير المدارس وج صبحي مطخ علينا من
امبارح لما انهم طلعوا قلنا اليوم ابسر
نلاقيهم في قلب هذا بحمد الله هذا من كرم
الله هذا لقينا
المنا وينهم والله يا ابن عم طرت علينا
والله تبهدلنا تبهدلنا خص عدتنا كلها
رميناها كل اغراضنا رميناه حتى حتى اكل ما
قدرنا ناكل كل ما بنجي نفتح الشط بطخ
علينا قوات الاحتلال تطلق من الاخر الناار
تجاه النازحين وهناك شهادات من قبل
المواطنين بان هناك اعداد كبيره من
الاصابات داخل معسكر خانيونس وداخل حي
الامل وكذلك هناك اعداد من الشهداء ملقا
جث منينهم على الارض في حين ان هناك عديد
النازحين متواجدين داخل مدارس الاواء
بالقرب من مستشفى ناصر في المحافظه حتى
هذه اللحظه حركه النزوح مستمره باتجاه
اقصى غرب خانيونس ولا يعلم المواطنون
دائما اين سيتجهون في ظل هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي المستمر عليهم لقناه الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس